Hola Andrés efectivamente la situación
se mantiene tensa aquí en ante en este
momento nuestro equipo está
desplazándose entre la prefectura de
esta ciudad y la ciudadela Pablo Picasso
donde de donde recibía El joven
asesinado puedo decirte que la situación
es muy tensa hemos podido comprobar aquí
en el terreno una cantidad que como
vemos en las imágenes de automóviles
quemados y ese dispositivo policial
adicional que se ha desplegado con cerca
de dos mil agentes adicionales en los
suburbios de París hemos visto pasar
varios autos y también camiones de la
policía por aquí hay zonas de seguridad
particularmente tensas particularmente
delicadas es la ciudad de la Paulo
Picasso como decía donde residía es la
la víctima y otra ciudadela llamada
Puente Viejo donde el equipo de France
veinticuatro también conversó con varias
personas sobre todo eh adultos que
expresaban su inquietud por la
irritación que tienen los más jóvenes en
esos lugares una irritación que en algún
momento se va a canalizar y ejemplo de
ello como tú lo mencionabas lo vimos
anoche por el momento pensión pero
enfrentamientos como los de anoche
todavía no hemos podido apreciar aquí en
el terreno ahora hubo varios llamados a
la calma por parte de las autoridades en
Francia qué se espera durante la jornada
de la noche por ejemplo
Bueno ya lo decíamos cerca de 2000
agentes de la policía desplegados Eso
quiere decir que el gobierno estima que
la violencia estallará nuevamente Habría
que ver hay que esperar que pasen
algunas horas para saber si esos
llamados a la calma del propio
presidente Emmanuel macrón del ministro
del interior del prefecto de la ciudad
de nantea que incluso en su palabra fue
bastante se
mostró conmovido al decir que nunca se
había visto un hecho tan atroz aquí en
la ciudad delantero y también hechos de
violencia como lo que se registraron
anoche hemos visto también
grafitis sobre las paredes que muestran
varios mensajes justicia para enel aquí
No nos vamos a detener es decir que una
cierta amenaza que van a continuar las
acciones como las de anoche y también el
nombre de el policía que valió al joven
anoche